Join me now to discuss all of this, the
warning, the attacks, future attacks
that could happen. He's the author of
the book Iran, an imperialist republic
in US policy, along with being a former
Trump foreign policy advisor, Dr. Walid
Phares. Joining him, the author of the
book Holy Hell and director of Jihad
Watch, Robert Spencer.
Gentlemen, welcome back to the program.
I want to begin in Austin
and go from there.
Um
and let me start with Robert.
Unfortunately, Robert, this is probably
not going to be the last attack,
especially when we know the floodgates
were opened for 4 years.
Somewhere between 15 and 20 million
illegal aliens came in.
I don't know if hundreds of thousands or
millions of them were Muslims, and I
don't know how many of them will get
radicalized. But obviously, this guy
got radicalized real quick, right? We
started the strikes the beginning of the
weekend, and by Sunday, he's grabbing a
rifle, taking his trusty Quran, wearing
that damn flag and property of Allah,
and going and killing Americans.
Robert?
The thing is, it's not necessarily an
open and shut case that he was a lone
wolf actor who just got mad because we
took out the Ayatollah. The Islamic
Republic has been recruiting jihadis in
the United States and having them
trained here to be sleeper agents to be
activated on orders. This guy was a
Senegalese national who, as you noted,
became a naturalized American citizen.
Now, why would a Senegalese
be killing people because of the Islamic
Republic of Iran? Because he is possibly
in the hire of the Islamic Republic of
Iran. They don't want to get Iranians to
be their sleeper agents because that's
obviously the people that we're going to
be looking for. So, they go to other
Muslims who are susceptible to the jihad
ideology, they pay them, they train
them, and they're ready to strike. This
is something that we know is happening.
Unfortunately, we don't know who is
involved specifically. But I think when
this guy shows up with the Islamic
Republic shirt
uh
that's why the JTTF is looking into this
because he could have been already in
position ready to strike when he got
orders from the Islamic Republic.
>> Mhm.
Walid, weigh in.
Well, uh Robert and I have been trying
to send those messages to the American
public, to the government before 9/11.
We are creatures from before 9/11. And
for all these decades, we have been and
I have been also working with agencies
to draw to them what would constitute a
jihadist. And in this case, it's very
complex. Yes, he's from Senegal, from
West Africa, but we've seen cases from
Nigeria, from Mali, uh from around the
world, Asian, uh European, blonde,
blue-eyed Europeans. What is common to
them is that at one point, they were
radicalized. And before that,
indoctrinated. So, this could come from
the school, this could come from the
neighborhood, from the mosque, from
everywhere. And now, of course, this is
the first line of attack or
counterattack by the regime. They have
ways to, you know, to trigger them. It
doesn't have to be they are sitting in a
cell of 12 people and are telling them,
"Go and attack." There are messages that
comes to them and then they start
whatever target of infidels they could
find, they'll go at it.
>> Right. And there's NGOs and groups in
this country that are funding the crap,
right? You got the Muslim Brotherhood
giving cash to CAIR, c a a r, look them
up, folks. They're bad news. And you've
got American citizens out there like
promoting CAIR and and buttering up to
the Muslim Brotherhood. If I see one
more American Catholic try to act like
partnering with the Muslim Brotherhood
and CAIR is a good thing because they
hate Jews so bad. And now they're
hitting on Trump for starting this war,
which he didn't start. The regime
started it years ago. I'm sorry. You
took our hostages in '79. You killed our
Marines in '83. And I can keep going
down the laundry list of Americans
you've killed for 40-plus years. You
started it, and Trump's going to finish
it. But, talk about that because there's
a lot of rhetoric happening in our
country right now by American countrymen
and women
siding with these And I'm going to say
it, and I don't care if I take hell for
it. These evil Muslims that want us
dead. No, I'm not condemning all billion
Muslims on the planet. I know there's
peace-loving ones. But, there's also
radicalized ones that want every
Christian and Jewish person on this
planet dead. And we've imported them to
the homeland.
Robert.
It's a bitter irony, Dan. It's
incredible. I'm seeing leftists on
social media saying, "Oh, dear Iranian
people, I'm so sorry. On behalf of the
American people, I apologize." And then
all these Iranians coming in and saying,
"What are you talking about? What are
you apologizing for? We're celebrating."
>> They wanted it. And it just shows the
incredible chasm between the left's view
of the world and reality.
Walid, your thoughts on that as well.
Yeah, I'm going to add a couple layers
here. I have been a professor of
political science for many years, like
maybe 20 years. And I have seen what the
jihadists are doing
at the level zero, which is the
classroom. If you
confuse the classroom, I would say if
you control the classroom, it goes to
the newsroom, right? Who Who goes from
the classroom to the
the the journalist who have received the
wrong information. And from the
newsrooms to the courtroom to the war
room to the art room to everything that
constitute the public culture that we
have. And now years later, we're asking,
"Where did they come from?" Well, they
come from our universities. And then we
realize that the the regime there and
other Islamist regime in the region have
been funding I mean, when you talk about
billion dollars, you are transforming
our classrooms into the army that is
going to destroy us. And I just want to
play one quick clip and I'll get you
guys to sound off. I got less than a
minute left, but I got to show this
because you brought it up. Thank you,
Walid. I don't even think you knew I was
going to play this. Starts in the
classroom, goes over the media. This is
a CBS News reporter for the Austin
affiliate. His name is Vinnie something
or other. Watch this. He's not on air,
but somebody recorded and put it out
there. His boss calls him while he's
covering the pro-Trump
rally in Austin where they were thanking
Trump for taking out the Ayatollah.
Anyway, just watch this.
Bravo to that reporter. He gets a text
from his boss saying stop covering the
pro stuff cuz it's making Trump look
good. And he says, "Well, I'm going to."
I hope they don't fire that kid because
that's a journalist. That's what was
happening in Austin. People were
thanking President Trump. Real
Iranian-Americans were thanking him and
the damn fake news media wanted that
reporter to lie. Gentlemen, I'll let you
take it. 30 seconds left.
I would say this Oh, go ahead, Robert.
Go ahead, Robert. Sorry, Walid. Uh
I'm just saying that that's exactly the
problem that we have that Walid sketched
out. That these people have been trained
and they are anti-American and they are
in positions of power and influence.
They have been for decades. They have
destroyed several generations of
American students. It's no wonder we saw
all those cadres out on college campuses
agitating for Hamas and now they're
agitating for the Islamic Republic while
the Iranians are glad the Islamic
Republic is on its last leg.
>> It's disgusting. Walid, I'll give you
the final word.
That is the jihadi machine that is
ordering a journalist not to report
because they are panicking. They see
tens of thousands of Iranian-Americans
not for Gaza and for Hamas and for
globalizing the intifada, but for
freedom, for the support against the
jihadists, and they are telling the
truth. President Trump is the one who
gave that order. So, they were panicking
and they want to crush the truth, but
the crucial the truth is uncrushable
like shows with yourself and others.
Thank you. Dr. Walid Phares, author
Robert Spencer, director of Jihad Watch.
Gentlemen, thank you so much. Appreciate
you.